i think there's really just three
scenarios that exist
when it comes to dealing with a a
woman's girlfriends
um dealing with difficult girlfriends
um she's either gonna want you
she's gonna hate you or she's going to
be indifferent about you
women are hypergamous we know this so
they're always going to want the bigger
better deal so if she doesn't have a guy
in her life or has a bit of a loser guy
in her life and her best friend's guy
looks more attractive better option
women do tend to steal dudes you know
from their girlfriends or they'll or
they'll sleep with them or they'll you
know pull any number of things so it's
an either
a desire thing like she wants him
it's she hates them which is the other
side of the spectrum where she's
basically just going to talk about
the guy he's a loser you can do better
girl
uh he's too
short too fat too ugly too bald too
hairy to
whatever you know she wants to insert
but
apparently he's not good enough and she
wants her to leave the dude or to go
find something better this often happens
with women when they live miserable
lives and they have nothing going on
then what they'll tend to do is like
i want her to be miserable too
i know he's a good guy but i'm gonna
make up a bunch of and i'm gonna
get her to bounce with me so we can go
back to the nightclubs and dance on bars
together
so there's option one she wants him she
hates him or she's indifferent
um
so let's take a look at what guys are
all saying over here so physionic
i once got in an argument with a
girlfriend of mine that lasted i'll go
full screen i know some of you guys
can't see it
uh
that lasted eight plus hours on my
birthday when we finally reached the
conclusion she decided to go to the
other room in my apartment and call her
girlfriends
her friends told her i was a cruel
person
you'll get that
um
why
i mean i always tell you guys you want
to consider the source you know would
you walk a mile in their shoes you know
do they look like they know what they're
talking about sort of thing
and
taking advice from a bunch of other
girls
calling you a cruel person this
generally happens by the way you
generally get get called a cruel person
if you set boundaries he's a big meanie
right because he won't let you post
provocative pictures on instagram he's a
cruel person he's too controlling or
something like that right
and then goes on to say uh that she
should break up with me along with many
other insults yeah it you know like i
said earlier it always follows with
insults you know so this one falls into
the hate him category so you know the
insults will be something like he's a
dork he's broke he's ugly whatever you
know they're gonna make up something
uh this influenced her to start another
fight about an hour later where she
called me all the names her friends had
mentioned i sat silently as i listened
then i got up throughout the dinner i
prepared for both of us and kicked her
out of my apartment and life
that's what i'm talking about that's how
you respond
she begged me not to break up with her
but she unfortunately listened to her
friends and i lost her by her own
admission the best relationship she ever
had my advice is vet her friends just as
much as you vet her do they disagree
with her
or do they only enable her emotional
outbursts if so it's a deal breaker
lesson learned
all right this guy's red pill as he
must have read my book
this dude's unplugged this is this is
exactly like if he were to call in and
say this is what happened that's
essentially what i would have told him
to do
all right let's see what joe has over
here and i'm going to move back and
forth to the screens i know there's a
bunch of guys over here in the live chat
but i'm going to get to uh some of the
questions there the super chats pop
easier for me to pull out
uh joe says my biggest struggle
or better yet lesson learned was
believing that my ex wasn't the good
girl of the group
all right so
we've you know we've got this dynamic of
you know birds of a feather flock
together yeah that's true
and you're always going to become the
average of the five people that you
spend the most time with
so
this guy over here joe is saying or
better yet lesson learned was believing
that my ex was
uh wasn't the good girl of the group
let's go back to the full screen
the good girl
if her friends are promiscuous
you can get you guarantee it she's going
to be promiscuous too it's not often
that you've got five women that are
total garden tools and then the sixth is
like a prude a virgin fruit doesn't
usually happen again birds of a feather
flock together right
she would talk about her two or three
best friends being a certain way but
painted herself as the noble angel
my best friends are doing this set and
the other thing i'll tell you what i've
i've seen this movie a dozen times
i have i've seen this movie a lot
you know
you go out with her and she's like oh
becky is such a promiscuous blah blah
and
nancy does this with all the guys in the
bar and so and so is doing that in the
bathroom sort of thing
they're just blah blah blah and as he
points over here the noble angel
i'm the noble angel i'm not like those
other girls sure why are you hanging out
with him then ho
goes on to say went to a girls sorry
went on a girl's trip to jupiter florida
came back and the virginia was loose
look at the language he uses literally
the things you learn over the years from
being
what did she get it on with freaking
hippopotamus dude
um
things you learn over the years from
being in an ltr is painful and
phenomenal at the same time put yourself
first like these creators say you don't
have to be a narcissist or prick just
don't put your career your hobbies or
move somewhere you don't want to go for
a girl it never ends well
he's absolutely right dude is also
unplugged
that's how it goes
let's see what doug's got to say dougie
boy speaking of dougie boy did you guys
see the new raptor
bronco raptor just got revealed today i
was watching doug demuro doing a walk
around on it
[Music]
daddy likes
anyway doug here says
basically all my last ex's friends were
intersectional feminists
what the hell is an intersexual feminist
like
anyway uh she wasn't always like them
but eventually brought up their rhetoric
we got into an argument and she started
spouting all the man-hating feminist bs
i told yeah that usually boils down to
the patriarchy oppression blah blah blah
you know the standard stuff so
you can't you know you can't please
those women i mean i i explicitly say in
my book in the 20 red flag chapters not
to mess with women like that
it's about a man hating blah blah blah
she didn't so i left if her friends are
shitty people she will eventually become
just like them back to my point
you will become the average of the five
people you spend the most time with
you guys know exactly what i'm talking
about
all right let's see what igor's got here
for us sorry i'm gonna go back full
screen where's the full screen there we
go
story time
my now wife of 15 and yours
and i met when our common friend female
relevant to the story introduced us to
each other we started dating as soon and
soon practically forgot about that
friend she became very jealous told my
then girlfriend that i'm a womanizer and
that i'd bang every girl i meet and that
she was just one of many
why would you introduce your friend to a
guy like that
you know if you're so good and wholesome
and all that sort of stuff
we cut contact with her completely and
now the climax of the story i had been
friend zoned by that girl for like a
year or more at that time
so he wanted to get with the girl
the girl didn't want to get with the
friend zone boy introduce his friend's
own boy to another girl and then starts
making up stories about friendzone boy
being a player
[Laughter]
she hates the dude she just whatever
let's see what bill's got to say for us
my only struggle was realizing that the
opinion of my girlfriend's friends of me
was irrelevant after several learning
experiences i learned not to give a
deep
if my girlfriend wants to listen to the
jaded and biased opinions of her
relationship bankrupt friends and they
often are i mean
they are
a train wreck you know like imagine
taking the advice of somebody living a
train wreck life but that's what women
do right because they're they're very
it's not even tribal they're just
cliquey you know like i've seen women
maintain friendships
with
utter and complete losers
from their high school years just
because well i had known becky for so
long so you know i can't exclude her
from the circle
that's what women do right they
allow these
anchors in their lives
i tell i tell guys all the time anchors
are sales right sales fill with win take
you to your next passage anchors hold
you back
women are real bad with anchors
i'll just keep becky around because you
know she's part of the social group and
i've known her since high school
meanwhile
she's moved on making a quarter million
dollars here doing something with her
life has a happy marriage with a dude
but you know becky's holding things back
because she's a nerd but let's keep her
in the circle
it's not just guys that complicate their
lives and justify why women do it too
my last go around i called a group of
her friends the bitter club
and she
and she said she wasn't just a member
but the president
ended that relationship changed my
criteria so i'm blissfully happy oh yeah
those boss girls you can go girl
you know more than me and i admire the
help you give other men not to settle
it's hard and real enjoy your content
very much alpha lives matter
unplugged lives matter
router i had a girlfriend that had a lot
of girlfriends that liked to party were
into drugs or were sleeping around
frequently as a result she was
constantly tempted to join them and
constantly mocking for having and
constantly mocked for having a boring
life
you know guys
the way that this dude at the top here
handled it
okay where he basically said i threw out
the dinner and i sent her off
personally that's my favorite response
mechanism other guys are going to want
to argue negotiate deal with like why
why would you want to unnecessarily
complicate your life
you know it's one of the things that
drives me nuts about man like i see you
guys do it all the time
i like her and she's got a relationship
with my kids
sort of thing and it's like
yeah but she's toxic
yeah i know
yeah but that sounds like a lot of work
yeah i know but
[Music]
don't do that
don't do that i mean
do it if you want all i'm saying is i
don't do that
why would you want to complicate your
life unnecessarily
be like what's this what's this dude's
name again physionic
what else we got here i like to party in
drugs we covered that one
if she has a lot of difficult friends
there's a good chance she's going to be
difficult as well be careful a wise man
once said show me your five best friends
and i'll show you who you are absolutely
i once had an argument with a lady on
facebook years ago stupid argument she's
why would you argue with a woman on
facebook
oh guys
stop arguing with women especially on
social media don't argue with anybody on
social media
morons most of them
a stupid argument she started because i
said congrats to another guy for his job
promotion all right so dude says
congrats to a guy on facebook for his
job promotion and then she initiates an
argument yes you read that right next
thing i know three people on her friends
list are online bashing me over this bs
that she started my point is that if you
guys can avoid a woman who spends a lot
of time on social media with her three
thousand friends you are much better off
hey look you know anybody that spends
too much time on social media arguing
with other people you don't want them
around you trust me
get away from the gossipy bull crap
how to deal with a woman's typical
girlfriends don't birds of a feather
flock together isn't that what i said
if she doesn't already have a
respectable friend group she's not
worthy of a committed relationship the
headache is not worth the upkeep spinner
is a plate friends with benefits
whatever it is you want to do you just
don't invite a woman that's got
difficult girlfriends should not be
invited into your life
simple as that if she hangs out with
five losers she's gonna be the six
simple as that why would you invite that
in your life
you're just gonna unnecessarily
complicate it and then you're gonna be
like i don't understand rich my life's
complicated what's going on and it's
like
dude wake up
what's corey got corey smith says i
learned that a woman who
is who she hangs out with yup doesn't
matter how she acts in front of you
she can go back to being like them in a
heartbeat
she was that way before you met her
she'll be that way after gone put
yourself first and listen to your
instincts
wired
they're pretty much saying all the same
thing
lsg i have made it very clear how i feel
about my girlfriend's friends since the
beginning and thought and throughout our
relationship some of our friends are
just so stupid it's not even funny we
are the only
sorry we are one of the only couples
both of our friend groups that aren't
married or have kids and holy christ the
show that
the show that came out of her
friends are going through right now is
comical i love when i can say called it
every damn time it's also funny our
friends keep pressuring us to buy a
house and have kids and blah blah blah
blah when they know that we're trying to
become financially set first i'm also
building working on my business and the
way people judge you instead of
yeah
i
you know it's interesting because people
will
often say you know well why don't you
buy a house and when are you going to
have kids and when are you going to get
married and blah blah blah blah blah
and
i see all these married people all these
married couples
okay
that are like when are you gonna get
married no no no would you put a ring on
your finger
but the truth of the matter is
is they're all freaking miserable
i've i've literally gone through this
exercise
of going through my uh contact list
i mean you can do it on facebook you can
do it anywhere
and take a look at all the people that
you know like you know like you know
them right like you've met their
their their family their girlfriend
their wives and other kids like you know
what they do for a living like they're
friends like you actually know them like
in real life
and then take an inventory of how many
of them are actually happy
in these marriages in these long-term
live-in type of relationships and
there's a distinct difference
in that ratio versus the people that are
not living together girlfriends are
always better than wives right when
people start living together and they
get married they have kids the misery
level goes up and i tell you the
encouragement that that you see in here
here
i think there's an underlying need for
them to want to see other people
miserable too from being honest
that's just what it looks like for the
most part
you